we've known each other a long time so
long and when I first met you you were
the new kid in town at the wide-eyed kid
like oh shucks a comics here and now
you're my boss we do this thing where I
do an impression of Joe yeah uh and I'm
always riffing and improvising what what
is wrong with Joe yeah I'm always
complaining about something in the most
hilarious way yeah and like I heard you
in the hallway walk past my office today
and you were just gone at Jesus so we
had Jamie our prop guy make make a Joe
and these are some of the ones that have
Jude
this was sitting there the whole time
the sad thing is I didn't even make that
face on purpose for the picture haha
just my normal face you're always just
like a pigeon followed me for three
blocks what does he want from me
homes my dog came back to life should I
let it in this is my favorite wanna go
on I love this one
you can keep the card Holmes I thought I
was taking a mask off a cat and I killed
a raccoon